now that I've accepted Islam I'm really
happy that I and I genuinely believe
that Allah is the best of planners if
you can unpackage this you should have
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him was a lie today he'd probably
get canceled Prophet Muhammad Allah had
an Instagram page he would have been
canceled hard nowadays modern day
culture is
it's it's degenerate um
I seek refuge in Allah
from from Satan the accursed tell me
that isn't the plight of Modern Men
especially young men today what's your
feel now with everything because now
they can only hold him until the end of
this month I managed to procure meals at
around 80 cents each so we'll feed over
60 000 children what was your thoughts
now on him being Andrew and Tristan
being released on the date that the
Matrix was yeah it wasn't that
interesting I've seen some articles
lately saying that you know a lot of men
with conservative values yeah uh turning
to Islam and this is concerning I'm like
hang on a sec that's a good thing
alhamdulillah brothers and sisters as
you can see we've acquired the property
and we're getting right to work and with
your duas and support we can go ahead
and get the Masjid and megadawa Center
up open and running insha Allah imagine
every person that praise here it gets
educated and guided to Islam here you'll
get a part of all those blessings and
rewards insha Allah what are you waiting
for brothers and sisters you're going to
leave it all behind anyway so go ahead
and invest in your Hereafter that's
Everlasting click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
[Music]
peace welcome to the diesel media hosts
I got a special special guest here in
this digital Studio
you've probably seen them on the Jets
and parties from the past and right now
but he's got a new way of life we're
gonna be talking about that way of life
also we're going to be talking about
Andrew Tate bringing up us up to speed
on some of the the BBC interview that
just happened I allowed you into my home
I'm doing you a favor give me the first
interview I'm giving to the public you
don't come here with a position of
authority you're not the police I don't
respect the BBC and some of the other
things we got a lot to talk about
with Julius aka the satorial shooter
[Applause]
let me into my face
and his final message
be upon him this is our religion Islam
Islam this is the teacher
show
yeah thank you I can use my name now
Jules I've been doxed so I'm happy with
you before I just I used to hide her
hide behind the Satori shooter a bit
because I naturally I'm a bit of a
private person but uh I went I went loud
to support Tate and you know my
Instagram blew up because of being
associated with Tate so yeah I'm out
there now so yeah jewel is good man
jewel is good a few years back I don't
know how long ago there's probably over
a year maybe two something like that I
was watching one of these videos I saw
you in it
and it was Tristan and Andrew they were
it was really Tristan was pushing you to
have a drink and you were you were
running to go sleep and uh avoiding it
yeah and I was in myself I say I like to
meet this brother yeah
I would like to meet this brother yeah
I'd like to give him down I like to talk
to him about Islam you know what I mean
because they see like from that time I
was saying you were you were kind of you
know uh lust partying than others or
whatnot and it was very interesting I
have zero love for for the partying zero
love for alcohol now I've got a nice
solid reason to with respect to Tristan
tell him to you know go away like I said
and he'll respect that too I mean there
is a good Brotherhood there is good
competition and a part of that was
drinking and the issue with Tristan is
he just he doesn't feel alcohol it's
almost inhuman and so one of his party
tricks is to get other people drunk and
and to show that it doesn't affect him
yeah I used to hate it like you do it as
brothers you know competing and so on
but even before I took shahada I knew
that that Hedonism I knew that alcohol I
knew that all these things they're low
frequency like it's I don't know how to
to speak about it in a more sort of
scientific manner it's all low frequency
stuff when you go and do a nightclub
where a bunch of people are drunk and
looking to have you know superficial sex
it's it's dark energy stuff it's not
healthy it's not a positive vibe if you
will for one of a you know better way to
put it and so now that I've accepted
Islam I'm really happy that I have a
reason to say no that's not the sort of
person I am I'm not doing that and also
a lot of people like oh you've had to
give up this you've had to give up that
show me a negative from giving up
alcohol show me one
like it's all positive man everything
all the restrictions that Islam brings
if you can call them that I see the
intelligence behind it because they all
have a positive net impact on who you
are as a man your ability to to work
hard for your family to stay disciplined
to resist temptation and shaytan and Jin
and all these things every single change
I've made has been a clear positive and
I'm very grateful for it alhamdulillah
speaking of that I mean I remember back
in what we say jahalia you know the term
jahalia the days of ignorance we call it
or
um I used to actually own a part of a
nightclub so when I quit drinking that
was the hardest thing was to be around
other people who were drinking well you
want no part of it yeah when you've seen
through the Mirage that Society tries to
push on your Western Society hey you
know get drunk have have fun explore
yourself maybe even you know you see a
lot of like say Vice for example pushing
drug use saying oh yeah it's good to use
this and here's some tips to how to use
drug it's all deeply unhealthy stuff and
so when you've when you've lifted
yourself up and again I don't want to
say anything that's inappropriate but I
really do feel like since taking shahada
I'm operating at a different frequency I
have a cleaner energy as a man and both
in terms of the external world and how I
carry myself during the day but also
internally I feel
how to put it I just feel like there's
there's more pure and more energetically
sound if that makes sense not not
engaging in stuff which deep down I know
is a waste of time and I see nightclubs
and I see all these venues as places
where
on an energetic level it drags you down
it drags you into stuff which we're not
meant to be doing as humans so yeah I
understand that wow um I remember when
um when I first um started to implement
a lot of the teachings of Islam I felt
healthier you know the I right away
established the prayer and I heard you
talking about you know the discipline
that comes with that how you are really
seeing the power of attending the Masjid
is right by your house superpower the
superpower yeah 100 yeah it's um because
I'm pretty busy I'm pretty tied into
Donia if you will I have a lot of people
who rely on me both family employees so
on I do a lot of mentoring within takes
organization of War my mentor hundreds
of guys you know there's
there's a lot of my my attention is
pulled or my time is pulled in many
different directions and I don't really
believe in stress or any of these things
but I do get to the point where it's
just it's constant churn and then before
you know what the day's over the beauty
of Salah especially you know being able
to walk across to the Masjid that's the
time you know your heart can be at rest
and I really feel the benefits of that I
go I I have a little ritual I take my
how to pray book I have you know I'm
still still learning I don't claim to be
any sort of authority I take my how to
pray book and I'll sit and I'll read
through because I want to be really
specific with with prayer and I'm
getting there I want to make sure not
only am I saying the right words but I'm
understanding The Words in understanding
the intent behind them and obviously
even just the simple Act of of prayer
there's a lot of depth to it you know
it's it's I think just learning the
words and saying them without really
understanding why you're saying what
you're saying you're missing a trick and
so I take my book in there a little
early I'll read I'll pray and sometimes
afterwards I'll sit and I'll read some
more there's no phones there's no calls
there's no hey I want this meeting my
attention is not pulled in in many
different directions that simple Act of
turning off Donya and focusing on on
on what's real and that deeper element
to life
it's energetically I see a very clear
boost it's almost like hitting a refresh
button multiple times a day I love it
and when I'm not in when I'm traveling
when I'm not in Dubai I I genuinely long
for it I long for being able to go to
the Masjid like I feel and this is new
for me I feel uh I feel something's
missing by not having that refresh
button set numerous times a day this is
kind of similar to my story when I first
started practicing
Islam and I start right away I said okay
what does God Almighty want from me the
establishment of the prayer five times a
day minimum I did the same thing I had
you know Kat Stevens use of Islam you
know the former singer he put together a
really nice instruction how to pray and
he had a audio a book with I actually
was putting earphones on I was opening
the book and I was reading it I had no
clue you know and I was saying but I
wanted to do it right yeah exactly right
I wanted to do it right and I'm the law
over time
and it's I've said this before I'll
start it again
I'm 40 years old now and learning isn't
as easy as it used to be you know I now
know how to spend I can take one hour of
my time and turn that into x amount of
dollars yeah one hour with my time and
turn that into x amount of positive
impact with its the businesses that I
run or the people I mentor
putting that aside and just focusing on
learning something can be a little bit
difficult whereas the time that I put
into learning about Islam
it I want more it's not a chore I'm not
having to force myself to learn if
anything I'm
consciously prioritizing my life so I've
got more time to learn and that's a very
rare thing yeah for example I have
numerous languages that I need to
maintain it's very hard to find the
motivation to to put aside the world and
you know conquest and growth and all
these things and just focus on
maintaining these languages I find that
a challenging thing to do whereas
putting aside you know all the business
and all the mentoring and focusing on
Islam I love it I do it every day every
day is part of my sleep hygiene I'll
read something about our faith and the
more I read the more I want to read
that's a very unique sensation as as a
man everything else that I have to learn
can be a chore whereas learning about
Islam is it's it's the more energy I put
in the more energy I get out of it it's
really cool this is similar to my
journey yes it was like I I never
actually read so much in my life until I
really you know I enjoyed learning as
much as when I started to really because
everything just made sense exactly it
clicks doesn't it it clicks I I pretty
much have stopped reading to be honest
until us until I took shahada and now
now I'm reading again so it's because
you know how it is with devices and with
phone calls and meetings is constant
churn I think your brain gets less
stimulus when you when you just take an
old school book and you know slow down
and read and focus on one thing nowadays
everyone's you know they're watching TV
and they've got their devices out and
having conversations with people putting
all that aside and just focusing on
something very slow and manual like
reading I think less and less people are
doing that nowadays whereas Islam gives
you that that motivation to just slow
yourself down and focus on what's real I
think it's a very sacred thing let's
back it up for for a minute so some
people are like okay we've heard he was
the uh your guest here uh Jewel uh
santorial shooter that was the the name
that you go by it was it was either
manager of Andrew Tate was he's one of
the best friends you know can you fill
us in a little bit and uh excellent so
yeah anyone who thinks I'm manager of
Andrew Tech you try managing Andrew Tate
so Andrew Tate's going to do what Andrew
Tate does and same with Tristan like the
idea that these two gentlemen will ever
have a man that's just someone's you
know not knowing who they are they are
ferociously focused on on their mission
and they'll take counsel and you know
obviously we have a lot of Chats on a
daily basis you know we'll bounce things
back and forth I'll put forward my ideas
some of them are adopted some some of
them are not the perspective I come is
that of risk you know I have a master's
degree in Risk Management over you know
a former career in in pretty senior
security roles for large organizations
and supporting ultra high net worth
individuals but there's no way that I I
could ever manage those guys they are
self-managed so to speak so close
friends have been for about five years
and the reason why I felt the
responsibility to go loud even though
doing so doesn't really benefit me I
mean off the back of my social media
following I sell or you know and promote
various tape products which I really
believe in both the War Room you know we
have a really strong Brotherhood there
and and the real world because I've seen
the positive impacts these things have I
wouldn't put my name behind something if
I didn't you know manually personally
see the benefits and I do
um so you could argue that there's some
benefit from from promoting these things
it's it's negligible in terms of the
financial return me being out in the
public severe
doesn't give me benefits people coming
up asking for photos I'm not the photo
guy I've spent years of my life and
especially my professional career being
the guy who's not photographed you know
it doesn't I'm not yeah I don't want the
clout or fame I think having social
media following is a bit like having
money in in Monopoly like who cares you
know it's not real
um whereas I had the duty to go loud and
support these brothers because outside
of their direct family I've spent the
most time with them over the last five
years you know they've been in my house
I've been in their house yeah the Jets
the Yachts these I've been in the the
houses where apparently these
allegations have taken place and I've
seen that it's all nonsense so I had to
go out and I had to speak and I'm doing
that to the best of my ability and I'll
continue to do it because I know the
truth I've seen the truth and as I've
said numerous times I'm definitely not
objective I'm highly subjective I I love
these guys as brothers as family but I'm
still credible you know as I've said
before I held top level secret
clearances in my previous lines of work
I've held very senior corporate
positions anyone who knows me was
interacted with me professionally knows
that I'm a good judge of character you
know I have ethics and and I'm a
credible witness if you will as to
what has and hasn't happened and so it's
my duty to come out and speak openly for
these brothers because as I have to
believe you know history will show
what's being accused is laughable it's
illogical it doesn't make sense and we
can go into details if you want I don't
know how yeah let's uh let's go ahead
and um let's touch upon that for some of
the viewing audience who really all
they've seen is some of the tabloids or
some of the mainstream media I've I've
had many different uh guests on and
we've kind of went over a lot of these
things I've covered a lot of it but for
those who don't know
fill us in you know I'll start off you
have uh some allegations you have some
secret Witnesses
um we don't know who they are you have
others who are coming forward if I
remember correctly or saying that we're
not victims but they're put on a victim
list then you have I don't know if these
work as a prostitute or stripper coming
forward from meloda maleta what's the
country or somewhere from uh Moldova
Moldova yeah but was living in the UK
when she met Titan as I understand it
yeah and then you have things coming up
from like 10 years ago from a business
now there's all of a sudden coming up
and please fill in the blanks yep happy
to do so so first of all I don't
represent Tate in a formal manner in any
way I'm his friend I'm not his manager I
also don't have the authority to speak
on legal matters and you'll be very
careful with what uh what I say but
you'd put your neck on the line here
yeah 100 any any court that wants me to
go and and
and swear in in front of you know a holy
book or whatever the requirements are I
will go on record and I will tell the
truth like I'm ready summon me I'll fly
him wherever like I'm quite quite
prepared to do it so so speaking the
truth as I've seen without in any way
representing Tate officially or in any
way you know pretending to be a legal
professional which I'm not
the allegations as was discussed in in
Tate's emergency meeting today are that
uh in 2021 the Tate Brothers formed an
organized crime group with the intent to
draw women into Romania under false
pretenses and then steal their Tick Tock
money that's what it is so so the claim
is that men who only fly private rent
super Yachts own Bugattis you know are
financially made
for some reason went to Great Lengths to
try and steal somebody's Tick Tock money
like insignificant amounts of money yeah
and and these tabloids trying to claim
that oh yes you know look at the
lifestyle they made it's from exploiting
women I'm sorry I I don't really know
the industry but I'm pretty sure Tick
Tock money doesn't buy Bugattis let's be
real here it's absolute nonsense and
there are numerous platforms that Tate
has such as the real world they have uh
I think it's 150 000 members or more
paying 50 a month with a very high
recurring rate that's where money comes
from from products like that which are
highly uh effective in that they're
teaching a lot of people you know skills
you can monetize and they continue to be
successful over time you know if trying
to say that they're somehow doing
something nefarious join that platform
and have a look at how active it is you
know there's no there's no mystery as to
where their money comes from
um so the idea that they're somehow
in any does it I mean as I understand
and again I never worked in law
enforcement but I did work
um with uh people who were you know even
in the security industry a lot of people
are excellent law enforcement as I
understand it with crimes there needs to
be some kind of credible intent as to
why someone do it
what's the intent for for financially
independent very high status individuals
to go to Great Lengths to steal
someone's Tick Tock money it's quite
simply not real whereas on the flip side
as we know as you get more famous as a
man as you get more and more publicly
known to be wealthy there are certain
individuals out there you don't need a
gender a man or woman who'd want to get
a piece of that Fame get a piece of that
wealth and the the individual that you
refer to the one from Moldova
the way they met was when she was
working as a stripper she said to Andrew
I want to get famous on Tick Tock
because I want
a significant a set amount of money with
which to buy a house now as I understand
it Andrew said well yeah I know a thing
or two about internet marketing I can
help you out the idea that he's somehow
deceiving women
she was the one who said to him she
wanted to get famous you know again why
does someone pushing a Bugatti have to
try and exploit somebody for tick tock
money the whole thing's completely
illogical and the way the media has had
an absolute field day on pushing these
clearly illogical narratives I have I
mean I didn't really trust mainstream
media previously to be honest but I've
seen firsthand that the lies and the
it's not incompetence I mean if you're a
journalist you have basic investigative
skills
this is an agenda it's a very clear
agenda being pushed consciously by
people who and you mentioned that BBC
interview people who don't want to know
the truth somebody some of the
allegations that that lady from the BBC
was pushing can be debunked easily with
a basic research skills she's a
so-called journalist she can't even find
it out and I'll give you one example
Lucy yeah one example was she said to
Tate
during that interview you was you are
talking about putting a machete in a
woman's face and being violent
and so hang on a sec that that's an out
of context sound bite which has been
pushed around the world the full form
video which if you're a journalist you
could probably dig up it's not you know
it's out there it's not hidden is Tate's
saying I have a lot of machetes in my
house if a woman for example found out I
was cheating and she came at me with a
machete what would I do I bang the
machete out I'd grab a restrainer or so
on he was talking a self-defense context
yet this so-called career journalist
can't determine that and she comes to
him with allegations he's talking about
being attacking a woman with a machete
it's there it's on record so again this
is not incompetence on behalf of BBC and
other you know mainstream media Outlets
this is a clear agenda where they don't
even care about the truth they're just
trying to push their narrative it is so
apparent and so disgustingly obvious
that I have to believe that anyone with
basic Common Sense can see that
the the the agenda at play is is is
dirty and not based on truth and that
mainstream media simply cannot be
trusted nowadays they've proven that how
do you think they handled the Andrew
Tate video a few verses the uh was it
Philip Schofield morning telepresenter
Philip schofield's brother Timothy
Schofield has been sentenced to 12 years
in prison for sexual abuse of a child
and his brother isn't that amazing I
mean Timothy the one who was convicted
that's a great example yeah it was very
interesting to see BBC basically showing
empathy in the way they were reporting
the Phillip Schofield proven case of
pedophilia as I understand it proven on
record whereas Tate has allegations
which if you look at them as a
journalist with basic investigative
skills you'd see just don't make sense
logically yet they're coming after him
with all these attempted gotcha
questions and these false claims and
these easily debunked with some basic
research and logical
um parallels that they're trying to draw
to think oh look we've got him we we've
he said something bad 10 years ago
therefore that proves that he would do
some sort of bizarre exploitative crime
in in you know in recent times it's it's
it's such nonsense and I have to believe
that the majority of the world are
waking up and realizing that modern day
media is not seeking and Reporting the
truth they are simply pushing agenda
they are a psyop tool that is not
working in your favor as you know as a
citizen
here here's the ironic thing that okay
if you are someone who's let's say
you've done some things in the past
right
you know if if you're saying this is my
position what I'm about now you know
just like in islamically like if some we
don't we don't try to you know hunt for
people's mistakes or whatever if
somebody's done something in the past
whatever the case uh a lot of these a
lot of some of the filming and all this
is if I understand this is from like 10
11 years ago this is a different
lifestyle different whatever
um why what and then now Andrew Tate has
a challenge he's trying to go ahead and
promote and have the
mainstream media I think he put
something out there a challenge for the
25 million or something for charity I
dedicate 25 million dollars a year to
feeding children both male and female in
war-torn countries I would like to think
that even the Legacy Media can agree
that feeding children in Sudan or
Turkish children after an earthquake or
Syrian children in refugee camps is a
pretty positive thing to do for the
world
in my last BBC interview she tried to
spin it and say that what I'm doing is
somehow negative because I'm only doing
it for myself
but this is the level of delusion these
people operate under
controversial comments but that might
have got you into trouble and so now
you're looking for a new market you're
looking for a new market of followers
who are attracted by a different sort of
persona I've always done the charity
work so that is obviously correct but I
have proof that I've always on the show
your work so you're wrong I managed to
procure meals at around 80 cents each so
we'll feed over 60 000 children and I
also promise to provide full accounting
and receipts to prove that that money
goes directly to charity to feeding
children in war-torn countries example
so this is the thing the ironic thing is
now and just showing them being so
disingenuous like okay there's a man
trying to do some good now he's trying
to better his life right why don't you
try to highlight some of these things
definitely why are you trying to just
get a highlight moment where I got you
moment and run with that definitely and
I think that's that's a very good
example of the fact that this is not
about truth this is about them pushing
an agenda not only do they not report on
all the charity that it's doing and that
he has been doing for a while he's just
gone public with it now everyone trying
to analyze Tate and so they can
understand him Tate put out something
called the 41 tenants of Tate and that's
the beliefs that he lives by and he
believes that men should live by and
basically it comes down to Traditional
Values being stoic being mentally
resilient and working as hard as you can
to be the best version of a man that you
can be to provide for your brothers your
family your society and so on not one
single journalist has even looked at
these they're on the website everyone's
trying to hypothesize and analyze Andrew
Tate and figure out what he is about
what he's not he's written at length his
41 beliefs that he lives by not a single
journalist is even thought to refer to
that in their their deep deep diving
analysis and investigation about who he
really is it's quite laughable to be
honest and this is why you'll see
everyone who actually knows Andrew has
come out and said hang on no there's a
nonsense and I I'm the single most
informed person on the planet as to who
these brothers really are because I've
been around them more than anyone else
outside their family these are good men
they're men who have fiercely driven
fiercely principled and who strongly
believe they have
the the support of uh I I I'd say with
with Tristan with God but with Andrew
to represent Traditional Values to
represent uh
old school you know looking after men
being provided as protectors you know
they're the family unit's sacred the
traditional gender roles are an
important thing all these different
things and to motivate young men to
resist this sheep programming this
demasculinization that we see on on
whether it's Netflix or music or
Hollywood you name it from all angles
it's coming dictates genuinely strongly
believe they are leading the fight
against all of that liberal nonsense and
they're prepared to essentially suffer a
lot for it they are prepared to go to
jail if needed
um and to take whatever heat they're
taking and all this
negative nonsense being thrown at them
to push that that positive masculine
message of pursuing Excellence I think
it's quite a noble thing you have even a
lot of people who weren't fans of Andrew
Tate they were getting fed up they're
like just charge them already yeah it
was like when he was in the dungeon in
the Romanian dungeon there and I was
really sad to see you know where were
all the um human rights activists people
stepping up why you got this man in a
dungeon now not not charged anything
where's the innocent but we got that
here but I mean how is that like at that
time he's out now but how many months
was he in he was in for three months and
he's still restricted to his house so
he's not he's not free so to speak what
happened now they changed some of the
charges something got shifted around or
yeah as I understand it it's it's it's I
mean I've looked at that and I can't
really comprehend the difference they're
just trying to say instead of it being
you know set amount of of one or two or
three victims are saying oh it's it's
bigger than that as I understand it but
again where's the evidence where's the
evidence and why would again logically
why would people who were financially
made Aid risk all of that and even
devote the time they're very time poor
they're busy guys to try and steal or
deceive someone out of their Tick Tock
money they are the claims what was
interesting was that and I covered this
with uh how's our friend money backs oh
yes Dylan all right yeah Dylan how's he
doing yeah he's good he's good uh I
covered this with him there was um was
it that was it them the Moldova lady and
the other one and they were sitting back
talking about how they're going to get
an Oscar for uh with the messages
through official sources through the the
you know relevant Romanian agencies yeah
there were leaks I've been a lot of
leaks pretty strange stuff anyway there
were leaks of the WhatsApp chats between
the two main complainants and in that
they were saying hey you did really well
you know you deserve an Oscar for this
hey we're going to go straight to
Netflix you know they are openly and
it's on record saying first of all prior
let's conspire to to you know frame
these guys essentially and afterwards
here's the ways we can benefit so if we
look at the two parties involved the the
Tates and the people making the
complaints Tates have no intent or
Reason to do these actions whereas the
people making the complaints they have
clear and on record intent which is to
get Fame to get money to to essentially
benefit from these false claims and
that's on record and with these
so-called journalists these
investigative experts they can't look at
that and they can't see which which side
of the argument makes more sense on a
purely logical level who's standing the
benefit and who's not it's very clear
you are actually looking into Islam if I
understood for like was it around 15
years yeah indeed I first went to the
Middle East 2004 2004 and then your
journey began slowly you know being
around Muslims yeah a lot of people
doing dawa as I Now understand it um but
over over that time I often say because
if you care you share it this is just
you know because there's a lot of
misconceptions you know what I mean
people have all these different negative
thoughts so I Muslim you know he uh in
his behavior and his attitude he starts
meeting someone people talk about
football baseball and everything why not
talk about you know the purpose of of
life and let the people decide if they
want if not just like you obviously
someone talk to you and here we are
exactly a bit more important than
football yeah yeah no I lived in Iran
Iraq Saudi a lot of time in in other
other Middle Eastern countries I lived
in Iraq as well and through this time I
noticed that that the men that I respect
the most were very devout practicing
before you went you before you the first
time you set foot on a majority Muslim
country were you stuck with somebody's
stereotypes and chop your head off
they're going to this that and yell
there so especially when I was in the
military and and you know the later the
specialist area that I went into the the
belief was not so much that Muslims were
the enemy but that they were a real and
present threat okay and so my initial
interpretation of Islam was that it was
a dangerous thing
um I mean that's that's the truth um but
through spending a lot of time in the
Middle East through learning languages I
saw that
wait a second the country that I'm
coming from Australia is getting
increasingly liberal there's an attack
on Family Values there's an attack on
masculinity whereas these so-called
threat-driven countries you know Muslim
countries where there's this dangerous
thing called Islam they are speaking up
for Traditional Values they are pro the
family unit they're rejecting modernity
and liberalism
which side is is the the just side here
if we're talking about the war of ideas
you know fifth generation Warfare if you
will which side makes sense which side
has a more beneficial uh outcome for
both individuals and at the society
level and so I realized that that I was
if you will ideologically on the wrong
side uh and and I mean part of the
reason why I left the military and the
work that I was doing after that was I
realized that Western governments
they're not necessarily representing the
best for for again both the individual
and for for society whereas when you
have especially in places like the UAE
where you have a system of Law and Order
and a governing system that is based in
religion in faith and in a faith that
has very clear guidance as to how
families should should run how you know
men should act how how Justice should be
administered that's a sustainable model
with which both for individuals to
flourish and Society to remain cohesive
and and as it should be as it naturally
should be for generations to come so I
really do believe that that the Middle
East is is that the future in terms of
places like the UAE I really do believe
that that's a society you'll see
continue to be a safe prosperous place
for generations to come inshallah and I
do believe as the Tates have said the
West is a failing Society you can see it
in real time becoming more polarized the
the confusion in in young men and women
as to do they identify as a man or a
woman or a coffee cup yeah it's just
it's becoming an absolute mess so I
genuinely I believe at this point now
that Islam is the only answer for both
individual you know welfare but also
over the long term but also societal
it's I see no other solution to to
combat liberalism and modernity which
let's be honest is shaytan I view that
very clearly as do the dates well so how
long did it take you to realize okay
Islam Muslims weren't a threat
I think pretty much straight away
brother like again the hospitality that
I received in in the Muslim world and
the way it's such it's such like excuse
me BS I mean it's like you know you
spend a little time with Muslims you get
to see the hospitality the love right
and especially practicing Muslims who
feel an accountability for every one of
their actions to a higher Force and and
to you know the fact that they will be
judged they're people you can rely on
they're people you can trust and the
founder of liberalism I don't want to
misquote it but he he said you can't
trust an atheist because they have no
sense of of accountability to a higher
Force you know I'm sure I'm butchering
that quote but the essence is there it's
if somebody is is their own God and
their own judge then they can do
whatever they want whereas with
practicing Muslim they understand on a
deep level I am held accountable to
something higher than me I think that's
absolutely essential both for you know
the ordinary citizen but also for
leaders of countries if you have someone
leading a country and they believe they
are their own source of accountability
and they are their own you know God for
example that's a dangerous thing they
can do whatever they want I think it's
they can pursue any hedonistic urges
they have they can they can be
unscrupulous in their their business uh
dealings that they can they can become
essentially evil beings and I think in
the west a lot of Western Government
figures are driven by shaytan I really
do believe it shaytan meaning the devil
the satanic force is uh 100 I think it's
clear as day yeah uh you used to think
that religion at that time you were
practic you were from what background
were you a Christian so 13 years or 12
13 years of Catholic schooling Catholic
School yeah I was pretty pretty poor
family growing up but I was I was pretty
sharp as a kid so I had scholarships
with pretty much my whole schooling it
was all Catholic schooling but the way
our Catholicism was represented it was
it was a chore it wasn't something you
know anyone was passionate about yeah
it's just yeah this is what you do and
my perception what a religion was was
once a week you go to church you sit
there you say some things and that's it
that was your perception once a week
that was it that's what I thought
religion was and then as I looked into
Islam more and more I'm like hang on a
sec this is this this is a different
league in terms of depth and completely
guidelines in terms of yeah exactly
structure as to how you live your life
so I I'd invite anyone who is a little
bit disenfranchised with with religion
or anything I don't need religion and
you know religion's not not for me
if you're in the west and you don't
fully understand Islam you don't
comprehend what a religion is because
it's a whole level of depth that people
just don't realize or appreciating even
exists
wow it takes me back just looking at my
journey and just looking at all the
different religions out there and you
can see like okay in one way or another
they're calling you to Creation worship
but really what fascinated to me because
it's not people think religion something
you're born into or your family your
ancestors you just got to stick with
that it's like your DNA you know what I
mean you can't jump from anything else
but when I used when I really dug into
Islam just like you're seeing it's a
complete way of life the proofs and the
evidence is if you want the Quran has it
the scientific Miracles the prophecies
everything this is not something you
blindly jump into that's why you know
you have that enthusiasm that Ernest
desire to want to learn more because it
makes sense over here you're learning
that that God is an animal a human being
or these things are logical it doesn't
make sense and naturally you're gonna
you're gonna distance you can't find
that that Love and Desire that passion
like uh like you have so what was it
when you started to see the Muslims when
you started to look into Islam when you
started to what what was it would you
say that really you know finally did it
for you after 15 years that you finally
were like okay this is indeed not a
man-made religion but this is indeed
from the creator of the heavens and the
Earth this is the truth what was the
final thing uh I think to be honest it
was concern for where the world was
going and the steadfast I wouldn't even
call it belief assessment that the only
solution to liberalism to modernity to
the degeneracy we see being pushed in
the west by modern culture
Islam is literally the only solution now
yes there are certain religions out
there such as Orthodox which are very
strong and they are they are holding
their own they're resilient but they're
not really fighting back to me as I've
seen over the years the only movement
that's really pushing back against all
this degeneracy being pushed through
Modern Western culture is Islam I don't
see any any other entity any other body
standing up for this constant
bombardment of you know being masculine
is a bad thing being feminine is a bad
thing you want to want to identify as a
Lamppost that's what you should do all
this illogical like we laugh about it
was damaging right it's very pushed on
the children
show me a more effective solution than
Islam and from that logical assessment
that all right this is the answer for
both how to how to manage yourself as an
individual and also how to push back
against the nonsense you know how to
save Society if you will then I started
practicing and I was like whoa there's a
whole deeper level of benefits to this
one the discipline the the the power in
resisting temptation and when you're a
man of means alhamdulillah I've done
well um there's a lot of Temptation out
there you know what I mean especially
when it comes to casual sex or head into
alcohol all these things it's all so
accessible you know if you've got a
certain amount of of wealth Islam is
really helpful in rejecting all of that
just ignoring all of that and also the
the deeper level and that which I'm
enjoying more and more is
because I'm not I'm not big on emotions
you know like it's I'm an Aussie you're
not very good with emotions but there's
an emotional benefit from from
practicing Islam
um in in a very Earnest and literal
fashion that you cannot deny if you pray
regularly if you take Ramadan seriously
if you if you say no I'm not the sort of
person who engages in Hedonism and all
that you know low energy frequency
nonsense there is health benefits
there's mental health benefits but
there's that idea of your heart being
still I I I genuinely feel it and this
is not an emotion that comes and goes
this is every time every single time I
pray at the end of the prayer I sit
there and I have nothing but gratitude
for having found Islam nothing I don't
pray for anything for myself you know I
pray that my family looked after you
know my brothers continued you know
steadfast in in their pursuit of you
know sir
Kim the straightforter but for me it's
nothing but gratitude every time I pray
I I feel an overwhelming gratitude for
having found Islam and and the benefits
the that that Stillness that I can feel
that I almost feel like I'm home this is
actually something I reflected on the
other day I've been out of Australia for
15 years I've been back three times yeah
there's a there's a I had this longing
for heading back to Australia even
though I don't believe in you know the
ideologies that are common in that
country the nature of everything always
felt very grounded and I think you'll
always feel most at home where you grew
up I longed for that feeling of being
home when I go to the Masjid now I have
that feeling I have the feeling of being
at home which I think is a beautiful
thing and and I mean I haven't prayed in
many other masjids around the world
other than you know the one across from
my house but I'm pretty sure anytime I
go into a mustard and pray I will have
that very clear sensation of being at
home and that was something as a you
know 15 year expat I was missing I was
longing for that so the deeper level the
emotional
sort of Life fulfillment and life
satisfaction that you get from
practicing Islam earnestly man what a
boost to life what what a what an
advantage over those who don't have it
in in terms of being a fulfilled
effective human it's real do you get
frustrated sometimes when people make
ignorant remarks and you know this is
like you know if they just spend a
little time you know connecting with the
Muslim hitting the books learning you
know you hear certain terms so when you
mention the Masjid I think wow if people
would make that human connection you're
going to a mosque a Masjid you know
place of worship no statues no Idols no
icons nothing is just you're going there
to thank the creator of the heavens and
earth to worship one and only one God
praying like when they say have you ever
heard this uh Muslims are the Antichrist
but it's a pillar in Islam to believe in
Christ Jesus he's a mighty messenger we
pray like him it's described in the
Bible that he he fell on his face and
prayed to God when you go in this Masjid
you're falling on your face
yes the the sensation of
of being in touch with something bigger
than you of putting your ego aside
putting on the other side and really
connecting with the source from which we
came so powerful I I pity anyone who
doesn't have that in their lives I
really do well so then you know the
greeting when we greet each other peace
be with you uh Jesus would say
you know the fasting that we said the
prayer the I mean everything there is
just the same the same system the same
way of life that Jesus was living how is
it now because uh you know a lot of
people will go ahead and have confusion
around around Jesus about what is your
connection now with Jesus now as a
Muslim as opposed to before like many
people don't know that you you is a
whole chapter in the Quran named after
his blessed mother and you can't If you
deny him you say one disrespectful thing
you can land yourself in a Hellfire I'd
say if anything I feel more
that I have more of an understanding
more of respect for ISSA for Jesus than
I did as a as a Catholic as a question
because it's I'm more motivated to read
deeper and instead of religion being a
chore it's almost a passion if that
makes sense yeah so it's I definitely
feel well I am a lot more well read on
Jesus as a Muslim you said uh you said
Isa yeah yeah do you have any Irish uh
background at all I do you do you know
in in the Irish they say Isa also oh
really yeah yeah interesting I love it
this is real name because the English
language didn't exist so Jesus you
couldn't even said Jesus yeah I love it
there it is to answer your question how
do I respond to the hate that I see
against Islam um I view a lot of as
ignorance I have a policy where any
anyone I see and before you go on
because I want to make this clear like I
get excited to work together with
Christians and other you know others
especially in these times where you have
this sexualization of children the whole
things that we're talking about but then
some and I always say you know but we
have so much in common there's so much
in common but sometimes because of these
misinformation the programming and that
you get some of these negative things so
that's you know just an introduction to
yeah indeed my red line if it's crossed
if someone insults the prophet Allah or
insults
um you know other key figures uh I won't
interact with them I won't talk to them
because I would never insult someone or
someone else's religion and to me that's
a character flaw I don't even think it's
about Islam if you're going to insult
somebody's faith
shame on you for being a person without
ethics and without respect so that's my
view and so there are a lot of I think
it's cool now to sort of speak out
against Islam or to question
um that various parts of the faith if
you want to question in a positive way
go for it let's have that dialogue but
if you're just there to throw out
criticisms in a disrespectful manner to
get attention on social media then
you're a scumbag and I have no time for
you so yeah anyone who has genuine
questions I think is a great thing
um how do I respond to those insulting
the religion I'll never be in the room
with them I'll never talk to them to me
they're not people who are worthy of
interacting with in any way you've set a
multiple occasions Islam being a system
to to make you the best version of
yourself 100 and you you're actually
you're I mean you figured this out you
didn't take uh you hear shahada until
well it was this year 2023 right correct
recently huh uh so this is powerful I
mean coming from someone like yourself
now you've you've realized that this is
a system that will bring you to the to
the best version of yourself 100 I think
if you practice Islam uh earnestly you
can't help but become more disciplined
you can't help but become more uh calm
and more focused again Salah is put you
know putting all the Don yeah all the
world aside and focusing on your
connection with with everything that's
real everything that's that's
Everlasting
um a lot of people in the west they'll
say they'll talk about the benefits of
of meditation or they'll talk about the
benefits of fasting they'll talk about
the benefits of you know trying to put
your ego aside and this is all
encapsulated in a book that's hundreds
and hundreds of years old all these new
age fans that think they've discovered
something it's all there and has been
there for a long time so I genuinely
believe now again I don't want to say
anything
um disrespectful but I think Islam is a
competitive advantage in that if you're
taking your faith seriously you are
going to be more focused more
disciplined more physically healthy more
mentally healthy than people who aren't
practicing in an Earnest Manner and I
think look practicing any any religion I
think is a noble thing however the one
with the most Dogma the one with the
most Guidance the one with therefore the
most benefits we have to agree is is
that there's so much structure and so
much
uh clear
guidance on essentially I see the
intelligence behind all the different
elements of Islam
it is it is optimized in a manner to
make humans the most
uh disciplined the most you know prone
to reject Hedonism the most ethical in
their dealings with others they're the
healthiest in terms of uh mentally the
way they perceive their Human Experience
and live out their lives the
intelligence behind this the structured
living that Islam gives you
is is crystal clear to me and and it's I
mean I see it myself I see it in other
people it results in you being a more
effective human like if of course we
don't sign up to a religion for selfish
reasons but if you were purely trying to
become a better person
there's only benefit there's only only
positive benefit from from taking
shahada and in an Earnest manner
practicing Islam we're in a day and age
where I mean you have a lot of it's a
big industry these um you have a lot of
self-help books and gurus and whatnot
and I mean why not take this advice
something that's that's been around
since day one I mean we believe that
Islam has been there since day one
because Islam simply means to submit
your will to the creator of Heaven it's
been there throughout time so now
someone like you very successful
businessman entrepreneur and you're
telling me you want to get the edge get
with Islam I really believe that like
all these these life hacks and all these
life hacks and all these new new age
sort of things you know the people are
trying to push it's all watered down
versions of something which has been
written hundreds of years ago watered
down versions from things that have
already been written yeah hundreds of
years it's so clear it's so clear and a
lot of people say they found Islam in
their darkest days I found Islam in my
best days like alhamdulillah I live
something I've I've coined a custom-made
reality my my family you know healthy
I'm blessed with healthy children and
good relationships I have fantastic
meaningful work you know I run numerous
you know consultancy in other companies
where I work with great people solving
you know real problems I have fantastic
relationships with Brothers you know
materially have have more than that I
would ever need I I gives a cat in a way
that I'm quite proud of even though I
don't publicize it I I really do believe
my life is is ideal Islam has added a
whole nother level of fulfillment on top
of that so yeah I couldn't be more
grateful man and I've heard people talk
about
the sort of state that I am as like the
dawa High you know when you're really
enthusiastic about it I don't think it's
a fading thing the more I learn about
Islam the more of a dawah high I have
the more enthusiastic I've become and
those moments where you're reading
something and you go that quick moment
oh that makes sense so for example one
quick one for the longest of time
throughout my life I realized the
underlying intent with which you
approach an activity will directly
impact the outcome for example if you're
trying to get money and you're you're
your underlying intent is you're
desperate and you're coming from a place
of scarcity you do anything you can you
might get that money but it's going to
be a very Rocky Road whereas if your
underlying intent for getting money is
one of abundance and one of gratitude
and one of I'm gonna I'm gonna benefit
the people I work with so it's win-win
I'm not gonna I'm not going to take from
people you will get that money in a much
more steady and more abundant manner
that underlying intent is so important
then in Islam I read about something
called Nia and the fact that we have a
concept whereas the intent with it to
approach them even you know when you go
in prayer you set your knee or you set
the intent and I'm like oh hang on this
is something that's written hundreds of
years ago that took me 35 odd years to
figure out if only I'd read it earlier
and I have dozens and dozens of examples
like that where beliefs that I'd figured
out through human experience I find
represented in in texts written hundreds
of years ago that the amount of times
I've had those moments where I'm like oh
that's what I thought and here it is in
this book is remarkable it's absolutely
remarkable it's it's incredibly
energizing and I don't think my dawah
high will ever fade I think the more I
learn the more enthusiastic I'll get
that that's what people are they really
get amazed at the fitra the human
inclination Islam comes and it fits like
a glove and if it hasn't been tainted so
much and do you see now I've heard you
talk about this because a lot of people
go away from man-made religions you see
people a lot of different strange
incantations
superstitions worshiping the creation
things that just don't make sense so
people go away from religion and a lot
of people turn towards atheism and and
you talk about this them shooting
themselves in the foot 100 and it's I
see
and how do we get them now again I I
Think It's tricky because a lot of
people when they take these whether it's
atheistic beliefs or liberal beliefs
even though those belief systems are
clearly not helping them in life they
have their ego attachment no I'm an
atheist therefore you know I'm going to
justify in my mind I think the ultimate
question to anyone who says they're an
atheist how's that working out for you
how does your view
your atheistic belief system benefit
your life because I can talk for hours
and I happily will and have done and
we're doing right now I can talk for
hours about the benefits that Islam has
brought me both in terms of making me
more fulfilled as a person making me
more disciplined and effective and able
to better serve you know my family my
colleagues my Society what does atheism
do to make you a better person how does
it give you for you know increase
discipline how does it give you
increased energy to really go and be the
best human that you can because one day
you will be judged it doesn't it doesn't
bring any of those benefits so again to
any atheist out there my simple question
for you is how is that working out for
you how's that benefiting your life
because personally I can talk for hours
about how Islam has and is benefiting my
life yeah it's logical I mean if you go
ahead live Islam like you said you get
all these benefits over here on the
other side you probably somebody who's
not too happy you got to avoid in your
heart and at the end if Islam we know
it's true then all these what's going to
happen if the death comes it's too late
to go back Hellfire opens up Paradise
opens up you missed out I'm getting the
best of this life and the best thing to
hear after 100 there it is and I think
the atheists will always argue all but
you know Hellfire can't be proven these
sorts of things what can be proven is
how your belief systems are represented
in you as a person show me an atheist
who's genuinely happy I
I don't okay maybe summer but exceptions
to the rule don't negate the rule most
most of the atheists that I've seen
don't seem like very fulfilled people to
me they don't have that sense of
community that we get with the ummah
they don't have a healthy Dogma humans
need Dogma we need guidance for life
from somewhere now you're either going
to get that from a religion or you'll
get it from Modern Day culture stuck for
Allah you know you'll get that from a
government if it's like a communist
system and you know you must your God
should be the leader of the country and
so on but either way humans crave Dogma
from something and again if you are your
own God if you are not accountable to
anything why not engage in Hedonism why
not take drugs why not engage in in
superficial sex if there's no there's no
judgment or no accountability whereas
with something like Islam or you know
the the religions of the book so to
speak practicing them gives you clear
Guidance with which to live a good
positive Life as a human why would you
not choose that you really think isn't
it you have the ego as an atheist to
think that you can choose a better way
to to live than something chosen by 2
billion people which has very clear
benefits in every area of your life all
right fine but again my question to you
our atheist friends out there how is
that working out for you how's that
working out that's the question yeah you
said something also is uh if you can
unpackage this you sort of prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon
them was a lie today he'd probably get
canceled Prophet Muhammad Allah had an
Instagram page he would have been
canceled hard nowadays modern day
culture is
it's it's degenerate it's it's an
anti-family
it's
anti-men being traditional looking after
those they care about you know it's anti
women looking after themselves like it's
modern day culture is such a terrible
place to find that Dogma that that
guidance for Life once you break people
out of the Matrix what do you give them
I see no other answer than Islam if
wouldn't wouldn't that be an interesting
uh phenomena to observe so the way that
modern culture and we see it the way
shaytan has absolutely taken over all
the information channels again whether
it's censorship by Western governments
or we see Hollywood movies pushing
certain agendas Netflix social media the
other day on Spotify I put a gym
playlist on when I was going to you know
to work out this was before I took
shahad and after five songs I had to
turn it off because in this gym playlist
every single song was about women was
about being a simp oh baby give me one
more chance I couldn't even work out
without this this program being pushed
on me so so the idea that
that you can counter all of that without
some kind of Shield or some kind of
structure which is what Islam gives us I
think it's a I think it's a fallacy I
think the the assault of the these
satanic agendas being pushed us pushed
on us from every direction
I put it to you that
Islam is probably the only or it's
definitely the most effective way to
counter all that if not the only way to
do it in the Modern Age and that's again
a big part of the reason why I took
shahada was as an individual I know that
I'm limited I know that you know there
are such things as Temptation I know
that there is programming from every
angle that you know through in the
western world as to to be the sort of
man I don't want to be whereas if you
choose Islam and you follow it in an
Earnest manner that is a genuine Shield
that is a superpower against all this
workers and this liberalism is
degeneracy this temptation to me it's I
think I see it as a very obvious very
easy choice I really do you were the
speaking of shahada and for people that
don't know shahada is what someone says
to enter into Islam to claim that
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the one Creator God Almighty Allah and
Muhammad is the messenger this will
automatically include all the preceding
messenger Jesus being one of them Moses
Abraham and all the ones that came it
just makes beautiful sense that
chronological order it was the same way
of life not a new religion Here There
and Everywhere it's the same way of life
so now when you took your shahada you
are actually that excited that you would
go ahead and you were you were sharing
uh given dawa to Andrew was it yeah in
the early year in the early uh time or
last year or yeah I mean for years he
and I've been talking about Islam and
for years uh he's been asking like
take both of them Andrew and Tristan
very deep thinkers you know but behind
the the social media
um
you know perception of guys living
larger cars and all these things they're
very deep thinkers at the end of the day
when work was done or sitting on the
Yachts of the Jets we would have those
big question discussions you know yeah
what are we here for you know which
which religion is going to last you know
all these sorts of things purpose of
life questions yeah exactly exactly yeah
and and for me having lived in the
Middle East for such a long time I was
always representing team Islam even
though I wasn't Muslim at that point
yeah so Tate actually took his shahada
before me I was I was surprised so
Andrew Tate took his shahada before you
I was surprised he didn't tell me he was
going to do it because I would have been
like Brothers still together because I I
I I told him and I told everyone I was
planning to I was just researching more
and more first
um and I talked to him I messaged him
and say hey man congrats on on taking
shahada what was the the final push for
you to do that was the final push and he
said two things he said one there are
zero downsides only positives and and
two it's it's the only solution it is
the only answer to to
to stand up to the way humanity is going
and the fact that shaytan has
essentially taken over Western culture
wow so then uh you you went on you took
your shahada it was in the you you
mentioned that uh such masculine men you
see that I'm getting teary-eyed yeah
indeed so that was one thing I found
like for me that was when you took your
shahada right yeah
in the local mosque now he's a serious
guy like he's probably got hands he's
that guy's got that masculine presence
and can you imagine how many shahadas he
would have you know facilitated
throughout the years probably hundreds
if not thousands and when I took shahada
I saw a tear roll down his cheek now he
grabbed
um you know his headpiece and he wiped
it away
and I was just I was struck I was like
here's a guy who literally is
intimidating in how masculine he is but
he's shedding a tear about the beauty of
someone joining his faith and that that
to me was a really interesting moment
and I've seen and I think it's a tricky
thing in today's day and age how to be a
man I mean it's we're under assault from
so many different directions you know
the Gillette ad being you know boys will
be boys all of a sudden it's bad to be a
boy toxic masculine all these sorts of
things within Islam you must be strong
you must be stoic you must you know role
model your own life after the prophet
Allah was a very mascular man but also
he was very emotionally intelligent he
was very caring he was very just and I I
think any man who is confused about how
to be a good man and what positive
masculinity is today will do well to
have a look at Islam have a look at the
example of the Prophet Allah
that to me is the best way to express
masculinity that's most positive and
most beneficial form I think it's a
beautiful thing and I think it's very
needed in today's day and age when
masculinity is under assault from pretty
much every corner you can imagine do you
think this also helps in people making
their decision also you have a lot of
people that say okay they live a certain
lifestyle and they see now Islam is very
practical and let's say you have men
right and a man now he's used to let's
say he's living a certain lifestyle and
he's got a whole axis of whatever he
wants and now Islam not only being a
structure how to worship your creator
you know how to deal in business how to
deal with your your family everything is
laid out blue how to go to the bathroom
every every detail but now you know also
the struggle now that a person might
have is saying okay now I got to be in
religion and I can only be here with uh
have one family but Islam also did you
see in this in this environment where
frandro Tate for instance who's used to
let's say a previous life he's you know
got the whole door whatever he wants
with uh with the counterpart right
female part here Islam given the open
Avenue where he can have up to four
families if he has the ability to both
lead not not just in terms of Finance
episode also in terms of that that
patriarchal leadership and time into
each each family unit does that thing
play a role also that that helps to like
this is practical it makes sense yeah I
think I've always said even Man 10 years
ago I used to say that Islam is the
religion that's closest to biology the
closest to the natural way of living and
throughout history and indeed in many
cultures today outside of the West
you'll see that you know the Big Boy The
Village Elder looking after numerous
families because he has the ability to
do so the idea that that's somehow a
negative thing or that those in the West
can judge that is a bad thing I'm sorry
in what Universe in what reality is is
anyone in the West in the moral High
Ground have a look at the West it's just
nonsense so I think it's a beautiful
thing and I think it's because I've
heard you talk about this also yeah
indeed I think if a man has
not okay obviously you need your money
right but if you have the the ability to
lead multiple families and it's a
challenging thing obviously big
responsibility being a good father being
a good husband being that individual who
is attentive enough to really take care
of so many different people if you have
the ability to do that I think it's a
very positive thing in a world where
everyone's saying wherever the good men
gone obviously there's a shortage of
good men who can lead families be good
husbands be good Fathers if you're the
sort of man who has it together enough
in life has experienced enough is built
enough of you know wealth and so on and
you can be that good man for multiple
wives for multiple families it's a
beautiful thing it's a noble thing and
so I think it's fantastic that Islam has
that codified as a sacred thing and I
think to be honest
one of the challenges you see in the
west is the breakup of the family unit
if you have a system through which good
men can provide for lead care for
multiple family units that's solving a
problem that we see in a very direct
manner so I think I think it's a
beautiful thing and I think it's
something that I hope
um that that that almost stands up for
because I see it's under attack in
certain countries I see that's illegal
in in the UK I think to have multiple
wives but but you can identify as a
Lamppost and you can shop your private
parts off as a kid but you can't look
after multiple families nonsense what a
logical rubbish there was a story of
Iman I don't know if there's a joke but
uh a chef was having multiple families
and then the authorities came and they
said hey we heard you got you know you
have multiple wives here and he was
about to be in some trouble and he
quickly he's like not even my
girlfriends they say okay no problem
they left oh wow isn't that interesting
I think it's a joke funny so if you want
to have superficial intimacy with
multiple multiple families that's fine
whereas if you want to be a responsible
man who looks after multiple wives then
that's all of a sudden illegal it's it
meant anyone in the west who thinks that
you know the Western moral system is
anyway you know above that of the
traditional values of Islam they're just
kidding of themselves it's it's clearly
they are on the losing side of history
and time will show that
inshallah so yeah a few more questions
I'm really enjoying talking talking with
you um you know seeing you come from uh
it just reminds me we all I'm a little
bit older than you and just looking back
and seeing my lifestyle and just coming
and that Zeal and passion that you're
you know just accepting Islam it just it
reminds me also of my journey and um
it's amazing and I and one of the key
reasons I started this program was
because I saw all the different
misconceptions you know you see in the
media and I saw what Islam promoted
justice peace Mercy love all these
things but the media is having the
people believe that it's about terrorism
something barbaric you know backwards
but you know to bring on these stories
and just another one like yourself
someone was very successful someone
who's you know telling people if you
want to educate with Islam now and it's
a competitive advantage in life and yeah
I don't mean that it you know in terms
of
like ideally you know all of humanity is
lifted up but there are a lot of people
who just will never choose Islam
for those who are practicing Muslims
your life is going to be better than
this that's that's the stone cold
reality so yeah I really do see it as as
a positive thing and just one thing I'd
love to throw in I've seen some articles
lately saying that you know a lot of men
with conservative values yeah uh turning
to Islam and this is concerning I'm like
hang on a sec that's a good thing if
you're a man with conservative values
you think the family unit's sacred you
think a traditional gender roles are
positive and should be protected and you
see that that
same sort of thinking is is codified and
and resilient and protected within Islam
then choose Islam it's a positive it's a
good thing the idea that the West is
trying to say all this is concerning
that men with conservative values are
finding Islam I think it's the only way
to really protect Traditional Values in
a traditional way of life I mean what do
you get if you break it down okay uh
Islam real simple you believe in one and
only one God worshiping the creator of
creation live a morally upright life
because you'll be accountable you'll be
accountable so there's accountability
and I remember you mentioning something
about life you know with that over your
head a day of judgment it holds one to a
certain accountability of oneself and
without that is on a moment-to-moment
basis yeah you don't have time to waste
with with Hedonism or drugs or
superficial sex you've you've got one
chance to to live on a daily basis the
you know most of him live on that
straight path don't get don't get pulled
off it by all the and that's the thing
now my favorite line in in all of uh
Salah is
I seek refuge in Allah
from Satan the accursed tell me that
isn't the plight of Modern Men
especially young men today tell me that
they don't need some kind of assistance
in resisting temptation resisting all
that liberal programming resisting all
the hey masculinity is bad traditional
gender roles are bad
if you have Islam that is a is a shield
it's a superpower against all of that
negative programming against wokism
against liberalism against Temptation
against Hedonism I think young men
especially today in today's day and age
where there's so much there's endless
porn on your phone you know there's
drugs accessible there's endless
superficial sex accessible young men of
today especially if they want to get the
most out of their Human Experience that
you know day-to-day basis I think they
need to seriously consider Islam because
how else are you going to stay on that
straight path sir
wow what do you think is going to happen
now with um our brother Andrew Tate and
I genuinely believe that Allah is the
best of planners and whatever happens to
me regardless of whether I am martyred
regardless where they put a bullet in my
brain what's your feel now with
everything because now they can only
hold him until the end of this month is
that correct so do you feel they're
going to let him go they're going to
char it brings try to bring some some
chart what do you see happening I think
in an Ideal World
based on not just the lack of Hard
Evidence but also the lack of logic but
also the there's a word sculptory
evidence I'm not sure if I'm pronouncing
that correctly the evidence which shows
that they are not guilty such as you
know these two main complaints
conspiring and saying hey let's go to
Netflix in an Ideal World all that would
be considered and they'll be let go
however this is a big public affairs
spectacle on a global level just letting
them go now I'd have to think would
involve a lot of people losing face
and and so I think you know the agencies
involved the individuals involved they
have a very clear incentive not to let
the take Brothers out which concerns me
um again if you look at everything in a
purely objective manner of course they
should be let go and or even just
through the lens of basic logic
um however this is at the level where if
they are let go some people are going to
lose jobs some people are going to look
bad and those people therefore will will
do what people do and look after
themselves and try and keep this
spectacle going I have to believe the
truth will come out in the end
um
I I cannot see any any way that they
actually get put away for this because
again if through and and Romania is
still a new country they they have you
know judicial process that should be
followed I understand that this takes
time I'd like it to be a little more
efficient to be honest yeah but I
understand they have process to go
through if that process is followed
properly then they will see the massive
holes in these allegations they'll see
the evidence that shows that the main
complaints were conspiring to try and
get on Netflix and all these sorts of
things and they'll see on a purely
logical level when you're pushing a
Bugatti you don't need to try and
exploit someone to take their Tick Tock
money it just doesn't make sense so I
have to believe that this process will
probably be dragged out for some time
because again people you know certain
entities involved on a loose face but I
have to believe the truth will win out
inshallah do you see now like the
confusion here is that I I think like
how because you have different
jurisdictions even in States
and then you have certain things that
are allegedly done and that these um
victims are in UK for example and then
you have this is in Romania so a
complete outside not just jurisdiction
but outside a totally different country
how does Romania and then they actually
were found not guilty in UK so that's
the irony here it just doesn't make some
of it just doesn't make sense as I
understand that the UK claims are civil
so there's just you know people trying
to get money yeah I I understand it's
not criminal yeah whereas the Romanian
um piece of it is Criminal so that's
that's the one that matters defeating
that is the one that matters yeah
I would like to believe that perhaps
this would be dragged out for another a
month rather than the years and then
then they'll be released however I am
concerned that it's dragged out this
long without charges being laid and as I
said there's all that evidence showing
that you know the main complaints were
conspiring to lie yet they're still you
know restricted and not able to move out
of their homes so I I I I want to
believe in in the legal system but wow
why is it taking so long you know it is
a concern in that sense I don't know if
you know Amir Junaid formerly known as
uh loon you kind of look a little bit
different to me today than how we've
been seeing you in those pop videos is
loon still in there somewhere Lauren is
uh working his way out of my system from
Bad Boy Records he he was with Puff
Daddy okay he had something similar we
were I was talking to him the other day
he'd like to actually uh talk with um
with Andrew because he had a similar
situation he was a very famous um
hip-hop artist you can look him up and
he accepted Islam and then shortly after
he accepts Islam he gets hits on some
conspiracy charge he didn't even do the
crime but he was now years ago something
came up and then boom they locked them
up and whatnot so do you think any do
you think there was any
um
reasoning here he ends up leaving
Romania going to Dubai shortly after he
says he makes up Islam and now he comes
back boom he's in jail do you think now
there's any
anything to that that because of his
conversion to Islam yeah they they
um I think they're just playing to it at
all I think it may have been one factor
of numerous but to address that point
um
by raising another one I've seen there's
even a documentary coming out trying to
question uh Andrew's Faith which of
course is Haram but there are some
kefirs who are pushing that so they're
going to do what they're going to do
that's something that's they're working
on it's going to come they actually
spoke to them the other day the idea
that and they're claiming that you spoke
to them yeah I spoke to the uh these
documentary makers yeah just to stand up
for Andrew the idea that Andrew reverted
to Islam for clout first of all the most
Google man in the world doesn't need
more clout let's be real here and the
idea that it was some sort of strategic
decision if you're living in Romania a
strongly Orthodox country
is it going to be beneficial to convert
to Islam of course not and also let's be
honest there's a lot of ill will and a
lot of incorrect misperceptions about
Islam that you then take on once you
become Muslim I've told people I'm
Muslim and I've seen very strange
reactions and I know that you know
people are saying certain things I don't
care you know I'm fine but for a lot of
people it does affect them negatively it
does yeah and so the either the idea
that becoming Muslim is some sort of a
strategic move there's a lot of
potential downsides that come with it
and one of them could have been that
Andrew wasn't viewed as favorably in a
heavily Orthodox country most definitely
I don't think it was necessarily a
driving reason behind is you know is
incarceration but I think it may
definitely have been a factor uh Matrix
we've translated it me and one of my
guests Hassan we translate it as the um
satanic forces how would you translate
The Matrix so my view is that because I
I
again after the military I worked in
areas where I I got to see you know
behind the scenes and see how the world
Works um
I think there's many competing matrixes
yeah I think there's the corporate
Matrix which essentially wants people to
be cheap and buy what they're told to
buy I think there's the various
government matrixes out there that
realize there's a lot more of the little
person you know the the citizens than
there are the leaders so we need to keep
them docile and keep them easily
controlled scared you know that's the
the fear levers that are pulled you know
that to keep the Sheep docile and easily
controlled and I think then you have
other matrixes such as individual
government entities that have certain
agendas they want to have PR wins you
know publicity wins they want to show
for example I'd say that Romania wanting
to show that it's a good country by
locking up a guy who's hated on the
internet perhaps is is a form of the
Matrix as well but I think the
underlying push behind the Matrix is
indeed shaytan I think it's how can we
push people off the straight path how
can we make Humanity more prone to
indulging in Temptation you know more
more accepting of Hedonism accepting of
perversion and you can see and
especially in Western culture the way
these certain agendas are being pushed
even on children that's very clear to me
that there's a strong satanic
um motivator or underlying intent behind
a lot of the the modern day culture
which you know is referred to as the
Matrix
what was your thoughts now on him being
Andrew and Tristan were being released
on the date that the Matrix was yeah it
wasn't that interesting what'd you think
of that I think so that's legitimate
that the dates are that's when the movie
was released there's no conspiracy
theory yeah it's it's proven I think
it's I'd have to view that as as a
coincidence more than anything but also
I'm still reading man I'm still trying
to interpret these things you know is it
is in some way I'm not sure there's a
lot of meaning here and I think at this
point Andrew Tate is more than just an
individual who says controversial things
online he's he's a cultural icon and he
is the leader or you know you could say
the permanent leader if not one of the
top leaders against liberalism against
the satanic forces that are looking to
destroy the family unit looking to
destroy traditional gender roles looking
to demasculinize men and also take away
feminine feminine Tendencies from women
women suffer a lot from all this stuff
too because they're being shamed for
being feminine or for wanting to have
traditional gender roles so you know
everybody loses I think it's very clear
that Andrew Tate is now a cultural icon
leading the fight against this push for
degeneracy and vocalism and liberalism
and it's a lot bigger than one man at
this point it's interesting you
mentioned how this is hurting women I
mean a woman just wants to go in the
tennis competition and here she goes has
a man jump in and he takes uh the lead
right isn't that why but he also if
feminism as a movement is shown to
damage women as well the more feminist
the country is the the higher percentage
of women taking antidepressants the
higher level of divorce rates the the
higher onological level the higher
levels of of conflict in a relationship
if man and woman are competing or both
trying to do 50 50 it's never going to
be as cohesive and mutually beneficial
as man and woman
you know having polarity and
complementing each other and living as a
team in life so obviously feminism
crushes women in its its current form of
course back in the day it's necessary in
numerous ways you could argue to ensure
that women have rights but in the west
nowadays what rights do women have that
men don't have if anything it's it's
flipped look at paternity court in the
way women are favored you know and so
many men out there not even having
access to their own children so the idea
that feminism is anything but a Female
Supremacy movement which ultimately
damages women and men and families
I think it's very clear and I think
that's that's the beauty of Islam you
can have Traditional Values you can say
no I think it's healthy when a man is
doing traditionally masking on things I
think it's healthy when a woman is doing
traditionally female things and I don't
think it's healthy for children to be
told they can identify as a Lamppost
you're allowed to say that as a Muslim
you can't as a non-muslim in the west
you get you you'll get canceled right
yeah I I still I can't I'm always
thinking I can't believe we've even
gotten here now you know that was
something that was just so obvious it
was some sort of scientific biology
everything it's in your DNA I mean
everything is theirs and now they're
convincing people that a man can be a
woman a woman can be a man and tell me
that's not one of the many sons that
akhara is coming closer man it's real
perversion in real time and I mean I'm
not in a position where I can quote but
what's uh Andrew was on the interview he
identified as a she oh yeah that's right
he's joking yeah hey I don't know I mean
who are we the question no no no no no
no
yeah yeah and that's the thing the
hypocrisy of the left it's the only
thing they're good at they are so openly
hypocritical and I mean again that the
various leftists have come after tight
their lives look miserable they they are
timid men they are disrespected by women
that often they don't have you know much
success in any area of life and they're
going to judge
men like us with Traditional Values
again how is it working out for you to
all the leftists or the woke types out
there how's that working out for you
how's the quality of your relationships
how how how common and and and
harmonious is your house you know how
fulfilled are you as a man if you were
you know walking through life thinking
that you know being a man in equals
toxic masculinity it's it's clear as day
but these leftists man they're pretty
good at being hypocritical I'm amazed at
their tendency to subscribe to wokism
and liberalism and degeneracy and
Hedonism live miserable lives as a
result but still defend their beliefs
because it's mind-bending to me it's
incredible uh some current that's going
on uh Trump what do you think are you
fouling what's going on he just got uh
so yeah I spent a lot of time in in
countries where
um throughout Africa Middle East where
governments were not even trying to
pretend that they were just and they
were doing whatever they needed to do to
keep power you can see they're happening
now in the US this is not Justice this
is clear
smoke and mirrors and propaganda and
nonsense for certain Power Players to
keep their power it's so obvious you can
have somebody like Trump facing jail
time whereas there's a whole bunch of
allegations about the Biden family
without getting too political where's
the media coverage on that as I
understand it there are images of Hunter
Biden having sex with underage children
wow where's the mainstream coverage of
that we know he's a heavy drug user we
know there's a bunch of ties in between
Biden and Ukraine and all sorts of
bribery allegations where are the the
investigative experts in the mainstream
looking to that again that I think
that's the the danger with the West I
don't think the cold war ever ended to
be honest I think the fight against
socialism and communism or at least in
its modern day form champagne socialism
you know that term the idea of someone
saying oh I'm a socialist while they're
flying their private jet it's just
nonsense I think that's a form of
control I think when you look at a
country like China with a social credit
system where they have that Perfect
Blend of we are capitalists and we're
making money but we're also Communists
so therefore we can control the people
in the optimal manner I think that's
what you see happening more and more in
the west that's why you see this push
for Champaign socialism for leftist
values for for essentially a communist
style state says again we look at
Stalin's head of security he was famous
for saying show me the man I'll show you
the crime the idea that you know a
communist government can pick anyone and
can find him guilty of anything and
they'll therefore lock him up that's the
same Playbook we see being used against
Trump in order for the leftists to
maintain power it's so blatant for those
who've spent time in the sort of
countries outside of the West that I've
spent time in but here unfortunately
I mean the majority of the population of
sheep that push to demasculinize that
push to make them you know compliant
feeble scared little sheep humans it's
worked and so people are buying into
this obviously nonsense and undemocratic
push to lock up a man like Trump when
you can see plenty of more glaring
issues that should result in
consequences on the Biden side of things
but this is What communists do man this
is what the left does I'm not sure
whether I should talk politics so openly
but that's my beliefs on these things so
um in summary now we've we've talked
about a lot of different things and
people can go ahead and get that edge
like you talked about you know that's
helped you and whatever someone has done
in the past you know that's the
beautiful thing when someone comes into
Islam they have a fresh clean slate and
you want someone who's going to help
better society and you want to feed that
so they can come a better
a better instrument to push good right
so just something for people to think
about you know the opponents to Andrew
or whoever and we're rooting for the
good for um I hope people are rooting
good for me for you for all of us we
want to see uh peace established on
Earth Justice uh we want to see good
families and a lot of people to be
honest we want people to be just we
don't want to push evil agendas uh
promiscuity for an occasion all these
you know anything that will destroy
Society like you you know that dark hole
that's out there
um providing for your families taking
care of your responsibilities you know
being a responsible human being and
these are the things that will help
Society be a better place and these are
a lot of the things that now you're
seeing that Islam it coincides with
Islam so let's what would you say is a
summary now what would you uh how would
you close this off to somebody who's out
there and you hear these terms
misogynistic you can hear these terms
you know anti-women you hear these turns
you know all these uh bad images that
come with a certain person's name and
that we've brought up or Islam also
what I'd say is I'll speak to the men
out there because I'm a man and you know
that's my lived experience if you're a
man especially in the west and you have
certain beliefs
such as traditional gender roles are
important such as a man it's your duty
to be strong mentally and physically to
provide protect
that if you are that high level man you
deserve a high level woman who is
supportive who is caring who brings
Harmony and peace into your home there's
nothing wrong with that you are complete
you have every right to believe in in
those traditional beliefs you have every
right to to live according to those
traditional beliefs and Islam will give
you
a superpower if you will a shield
against the liberal degeneracy the
wokism the the push of all these agendas
that you see against you and your family
members if you're a man who has old
school beliefs and you want to be able
to live by them in a way you can be
proud of and the way that's easier to
defend then there is correlation as you
said with the faith of Islam and I'd
recommend that every man with
traditional gender
Norms or traditional family beliefs and
so on have a look at Islam because not
only will it help you protect and live
by your beliefs will also strengthen
them and it'll make you even more of
that provider even more of that
protector even more of that good noble
man living a life you can be proud of
that is the benefit of Islam so I'd say
to anybody especially those in the west
who feel that their traditional beliefs
are under attack the ultimate
traditional belief
system if you're lies in that book the
Quran the ultimate code with which to
live life as a good man with Traditional
Values who's prepared to to stand up and
protect you know those he loves and the
beliefs that he has and his brothers and
so on that is all codified within the
system of life that is Islam so I think
every every man
especially in the west would do well to
consider Islam to look into it with an
open mind because my goodness having
recently reverted it is such an
empowering
approach to both understand you know the
big questions you know what are we here
for to understand the human experience
but also a system with which to live out
your days knowing you are the best human
you can be it's it's an absolute
superpower I hope I hope it's so
appropriate to say it like that it's the
way the fact that it's a superpower
living living by the system you know the
clothes in Islam it just gives you so
much motivation it's a way of life you
can live your life you can uh how to
live your life how to run a family your
life even was a superpower of a world at
one point yeah service it has everything
laid out and also just one final piece
if we're talking about role models
I I think we should all be very careful
of what we consume nowadays or who we
look up to yeah and a lot of people that
look up to say a basketball player or
they'll look up to an actor or they look
up to an influencer heaven forbid stuck
for Allah
if you want to find a role model who's
someone who can really say you know that
that individual that that's a man I can
respect
have a look at the life of the Prophet
Allah if we look at all different areas
from being a leader in combat you know
back in the day where it was swords you
know you're not behind a sniper rifle
with swords and Spears it's face to face
leading multiple families all the
challenges that come from that and and
you can learn about you know the
challenges you face with that with
business with with being persecuted with
facing you know real strong obstacles in
life but staying not just masculine and
strong and resilient but also very
empathetic and very just and very caring
if you're looking for a real role model
in life forget the influencers forget
the sports does read about the prophet
Allah that's an individual who deserves
respect that's a man that that's someone
you can look at and go you know what in
all areas of life that's somebody who I
would like to role model after who I'd
like to emulate I'm sick of all these
modern day influences that people are
looking at and consuming their content
how about consuming that content it's
going to do a lot better for your life
Michael each heart a famous historian he
ranked prophet Muhammed as the most
influential man in history why not look
at his life you read about Genghis Khan
you rang about is Alexander the Great
looking to Prophet Muhammad besides what
you read from all the islamophobes and
all the hate industry out there looking
through it that's beautiful advice
what's what's a better place to seek or
even to place your attention our time
and attention is a fine art resource why
watch all these modern day influences
who are famous for the sake of being
famous when you can read about something
that two billion people have chosen as
their truth when you can read about as
you said the most influential man of all
time that's a role model that I think
especially young men today should be
consuming the and focusing attention on
rather than consuming all that
influencer driven nonsense that's out
there you know I'm sorry I just I I keep
wanting to ask you more we uh I've got
nothing about time yeah because when you
talk about influencers it's it's such a
sad and it's a sad uh an obvious
hypocrisy when you see people like the
BBC and others and you get just blatant
misogyny with coming out of like people
like Drake for instance and many of
these other Hip-Hop star in the
disgusting thing that to talk about
women using them like cattle and they
just like you know disgusting words that
come out of their mouth why why aren't
you trying to shut down the hip-hop
industry or the you know rap or you know
people who sing such disgusting way if
you have such a high moral compass moral
High Ground where where's the for me I
think it's a very valid point I think
the only outcome that you can have you
read some of these uh these statistics I
had a psychologist on Dr Leonard Sachs
very famous psychologist and he was like
man the harm that this is doing too
hip-hop culture has a really dark Edge
to it I think the only outcome you can
come to from a very sort of detailed
assessment is there are certain Power
Players out there that want and I don't
mean I used to wake up I used to listen
to hip-hop all this stuff I used to like
you know being in the music myself that
was just right yeah yeah I think it's
that's what I love about Islam it
defines clearly and identifies it
there's evil out there there is shaytan
there are there are evil forces trying
to you know keep you off the straight
path without Islam people aren't really
aware of that so you know before you you
took you know the faith that we have
really seriously you were working in a
nightclub or in the music industry at
that time you thought there's nothing
wrong with that right as most people
wouldn't it was like whereas when you
are practicing Muslim you understand no
evil does exist in this world and I need
to take certain steps to offset that
otherwise
shaytan Satan will draw me into ways of
living that are you know less than ideal
are unhealthy but to your point I think
if you look at the chessboard of Life
clearly and objectively you cannot help
but come to the assessment that there
are certain entities out there very
powerful entities that want to disrupt
the natural order that want to lead
humans into temptation and want to pull
people off the straight path want men to
be weak want women to be masculine and
unhappy whether it's corporates trying
to just make people deeply unhappy
inside so they're going to buy more
stuff to you know feel good whether it's
governments wanting to break up a family
unit and take out religion so that the
only source of guidance that you have is
the government you know in modern day
culture pushing certain objectives that
that are driven by by real real
degeneracy and perversion to essentially
weaken humans to weaken family units
it's all about control and I think the
reason why we see such consistent push
against that which is natural that which
is normal against you know cohesive
family units against religion is because
if you are a God-fearing man with a good
fan family who who's you know inside
feeling fulfilled you don't need to go
and buy an iPhone that's the latest in
addition you know with the color to
match your personality in order to feel
good you don't need to listen to The
Fear campaigns the governments are
pushing out to try and control you if
you are a good God-fearing man with a
strong family behind you and strong
brothers that is against the intent that
we see of the various Power Players out
there to make humans into easily
controlled sheep I think that's why it
is the way it is when you go even in
this country when you go back in time
the more you go back in time you have
less you have people eating real food
I'm really into nutrition awesome you
got people holding on to that family
values and you have so much more I mean
a mental illness was almost something
that was non-existent people it was
there but I mean it was skyrocketing now
and again if someone is is mentally ill
then you could argue that they're not
going to pose any sort of threat to the
powers that be what what is dangerous is
cool calm capable collected United
Brothers who have you know specific
skills that can challenge governments
you know think about if you are the
Elite you understand that there's a lot
more of the people outside the gates
than there are view it is in your best
interest to have the elite as weak and
malleable and controllable and as
sheepish as possible we see that playing
out in real time it's to me that's why
certain agendas are being pushed on
children and all all this if you're
encouraging young boys to be so you know
demasculated to the point they want to
cut off their own natural god-given or
sex organs is that not Peak control over
over you know the masculine is that not
Peak control over Humanity it's it's
scary stuff man I saw Andrew doing uh an
interview and then he was they were
having um one of these guys on and he
was like my brain my brain it was like
they're infecting me
um I use the term minor attracted person
or math in the title and throughout the
book for multiple reasons
um first of all because I think it's
important to use terminology for groups
of that group want others to use for
them and advocacy groups like before you
act online um has advocated foreign
Haram send her to Saudi let her repeat
this Haram we need the will of God
we need Allah listen I'm right and you
see that um it's it's really he just uh
really beautifully explained it in in
his uh humorous way
and just back to this is interesting
because I saw so uh Drake an interview
he was talking about when he was
questioning about his some of the
misogynistic songs and all that he was
like it's just art
um lyrics can really be demeaning to
women a sort of fine line between
demeaning and fun and wit we have a song
like I just wanna
F every girl in the world you know
that's one of our biggest songs just
this and the other but then the
hypocrisy you know someone from before
who did these things you know obviously
now we're changing better for with Islam
but just the hypocrisy anyways so so
back to this where um where you have you
know
to go get a tattoo you have to be a
certain age what is it in Australia I
mentioned B18 18. to go ahead and even
when you want to take your child to go
and get a passport you need both parents
here in America in Chicago you had two
pets if he's not if he's uh under 16
right or 18. and the list goes on to
drink alcohol what is it uh 21 18 18 I
think here's 21 or 18 then less than the
military what is it now 18 18. the list
R-rated movie what is it 17 yeah yeah
true explicit uh content and songs you
can't literally like purchase they sell
it but smoking but what you just said I
mean it's just amazing that they're
pulling this over your eyes right in
front of you that a child at such a
young age they're getting him set up for
the puberty blockers and I did four or
five I think they just put something
this is where you had people protesting
that they're showing these sexually
exploited content yeah at such a young
age and then at another age you know
getting them with the counselor they
don't have to tell the parents
and bring in male strippers to dance and
Dragons but you can't bring in female
strippers because that would be
inappropriate like here's another that's
another thing you can't take a child to
a strip club but you could bring the
drag show to the yeah as long as the
drag people are men essentially yeah and
then New York spending like I don't know
how much uh a quarter of a million
dollar taxpayer money for this stuff
that's a whole different topic but this
is what's uh happening this is the uh
Matrix yeah 100 why why would the West
why would Western governments care so
much about such a small part of of the
population I mean look I've never met
somebody who identifies as transgender
in my life other than once in Thailand
years ago when there was a lady at a
hotel reception then she spoke in a deep
voice I realized it was a man yeah so in
40 years I've met one individual who is
in that demographic why currently as we
see every every post coming out from the
official White House or Joe Biden
Twitter pretty much is addressing that
very small demographic because there's
an agenda here and from what I
understand there's a growing uh body of
individuals who are lesbian gay or bi
who are saying no we don't want anything
to do with this we see that this is
purely the latest agenda with which to
control the masses and to push certain
agendas and to weaken weaken you know
family values and Traditional Values and
so on and we don't want to even even gay
communities are saying we don't want
anything to do with this we see the way
this is being abused by the governments
it's so clear it's it's and you know in
a few years there'll be something else
that they're pushing this is all about
control that's all it is so you need
Islam that's 100 again there is a shield
against all this nonsense there is a
superpower that if you put in the effort
you can benefit from and it's a lot of
effort it's man look I'm pretty
committed to my reading I still know
nothing man like it's wild I've been
I've been pretty serious about
researching Islam for five years I've
been practicing now for you know about
I'd say about six six months or
thereabouts you know and earnestly like
I'm doing the right things to the best
of my ability I still know nothing and I
still feel there's so much more that I
need to learn so there's definite effort
involved but if you put that effort in I
mean I'm very grateful to have support
of so many you know wonderful people as
well I'm very lucky like that especially
living where I live if you do put in the
effort into Islam you have an absolute
Shield against all the nonsense and all
the the agendas that are being pushed on
you and your kids it's it's a very
powerful thing it's a very pertinent
thing in today's day and age look we
need to work together Jews Christians
Muslims I really believe there is an
elephant in the room we don't believe
Jesus Is God Son of God we believe he's
a messenger of god let's get this out of
the way you have people in your own
family who are Democrat Republic you
still respect each your family right
we're the Human family so how do we get
this across to our Christian uh friends
and neighbors and others out there many
are seeing this they're seeing that
Islam is his last front standing when I
interviewed Andrew Tate for the first
time he saw this also and he was someone
who used to be a Christian many
Christians are seeing this even
islamophobes are almost like when
they're seeing all the uh all the
different in the churches the pope is
succumbing everybody they're like
command Islam is something to consider
now yeah exactly exactly like hang on a
sick yeah it could be something there
yeah yeah so uh what do you think what
do you say I mean this is so because
much we're much more powerful together
they want to split us apart but besides
we get this out of the way the whole you
know we still love Jesus we say peace be
upon him but now after we got the
elephant in the room let's get on to
bigger things yeah 100 I mean
for me I think regardless of your your
religion
I think it's very important to be aware
that evil exists in this world yeah and
that evil is after the minds of your
children it is after the health of your
marriage it is after your sense of being
a masculine capable man this whole term
toxic masculinity that's an assault on
healthy positive masculinity that's all
that is so I think any religion that you
choose to to pursue be aware of the fact
that you need to take it seriously
because the alternative is Satan the
forces of evil Temptation Hedonism
liberalism
these things have a very real risk of
derailing your life and so if you don't
actively practice a religion which as
per my lived experience the most
powerful and structured and and the one
with the most depth is Islam
then you are at risk you are vulnerable
of having your life affected by the
forces of evil I mean it might sound a
bit dramatic but I really believe that's
where we are as a species I really
believe that Tristan uh what do you
think did he actually is he close to
acceptance did he accept Islam or is he
he just has a much more of a where's he
at I definitely hope that Tristan um
reverts however he does take his um his
faith pretty seriously with with you
know his current Faith so I think that's
one obstacle to him reverting two he
does like a drink so that's going to be
a big step for him
um
but I I do believe that he's a he's a
deeply intelligent individual he's a
thinker like it's I'd love you to have a
chat with him he is so his perspective
on life blows my mind off him with the
analysis that he shares on The Human
Condition You know the social commentary
that he provides but he just doesn't put
it out there as much
um I have to believe a man of that
intelligence and that understanding and
that that analysis will eventually
choose Islam because it's the only
answer as to as to how long it takes I
think it might be a long path but
knowing Tristan and knowing his ability
to properly read the chessboard of life
I think the the inevitable outcome is is
him choosing it doesn't take much work
one I always say a sincere Earnest
desire to one another troop asking the
Creator alone for guidance and then
doing your homework I mean you look at
prophet Muhammad's life what do you do
it for money for fame for power for just
uh is this Quran from the Devil is it
from human beings when you one by one
systematic you knock these things out
you see that no this could not have come
from a human being there's too many
facts not fiction in there from a group
group of human beings it could not have
from from the devil it calls you to do
things opposite to what the devil wants
you to do and on and on then it's like
there's and then what's the motive you
know the prophet Muhammad who said peace
be upon him who said you would give me
the when they they said what do you want
do you want all the beautiful women
we'll give you the woman do you want the
pot we'll give you the status what you
know usually there's something that
people want you know he's the leader
that people coming he's sitting on the
floor not on the throne right if you put
the sun in my hand the right uh moon in
my left I'm not going to abandon this
Mission no the truth why what it's easy
to to find an imposter after you study
his life a little bit and you know women
how much time passes when women when you
have these frosters and they expose the
man right the guy who claimed to be a
prophet of the stat and then they come
out and they start name one woman that
came from his wives that came out except
as praising him that's the heart this is
very very you know powerful when you
think about it we're not talking even
talking about just the Quran itself you
know this is the meaning of the Quran
not the Arabic but this is another thing
you know this whole life is documented
it's not hard to find out if he's truly
an imposter just look at and look at the
message that he's bringing yeah 100 and
the amount of depth the amount of
benefit I'd say even if people haven't
really accepted you know tawheed they
haven't really
exactly even if they haven't really come
to the point where they accept that yet
that will come with time the more you
read the more you realize it's clear but
still you cannot debate that the the the
good that comes from earnestly
practicing Islam both in terms of
benefit for you as an individual both in
terms of benefit for how best you serve
your family your brothers your community
okay you might take you a while to
really accept tawi but man you cannot
deny immediately you start practicing
Islam you'll be a better man you'll be
more disciplined you'll meet you're
better out you know higher output more
more ethical just better able to resist
the Temptations in Hedonism and nonsense
of the world to me that's the starting
point which I think the Darwa Community
could focus on who can talk about hey we
want you to believe this we want to
believe that how about we live in a
world where evil is real you can see the
agendas you can see the Hedonism you can
see the Temptation through this book and
through this faith and through the
support of the ummah you can resist all
of that nonsense you can have a shield
against wokism against liberalism
against people trying to attack you for
being a man with Traditional Values and
you can go and know you were living on a
day-to-day basis your most ethical your
most high output your most disciplined
life that to me is the key draw so go
ahead and tell me so you had some
interesting happen uh your son he also
trains uh BJJ Jiu Jitsu and he he got uh
he almost got bullied yeah indeed so my
boy is um we started him with his boxing
really young both my daughter as well
and then my son continue with his boxing
at his first fight when he was seven and
now BJJ is the focus and my daughter's
gone on to gymnastics but she's got
hands she can look after herself which
is great but yeah just not that long ago
my son was confronted by a bully who was
few years older and I think a lot
heavier a lot bigger and I mean this
this speaks to why I respect the fact
that you've created an infrastructure
with which to to train your your son to
be you know that masculine provider
protector capable of violence but using
it in a good way you know the men are
meant to be like this despite all this
toxic masculinity rubbish that people
try and push so this bigger kid was was
had my my son up against the wall was he
was hitting him and I said to my son
because I want to understand you know
his mental resilience so what was it
like he said well Dad he didn't really
land any punches and and those he did
land I've been hit harder before in the
ring so I'm like okay nice there's some
mental toughness there I said what
happened he said well I was ducking a
bit and then I saw that he was punching
with his hands down so I I hit him with
my overhand right I said where did you
hit him son he said I put it just here
I'm like oh right on the button and what
happened after that and my son said and
you know fairly humbly I didn't want to
fight anymore after that Dad
and to me that was a very gratifying
moment because years and years and a lot
of money and time spent teaching my boy
how to fight not only did he demonstrate
mental resilience he wasn't phased when
someone bigger was trying to hurt him he
didn't get emotional didn't get upset he
kept cool and kept calm and also he in a
very efficient way without hurting the
guy you know excessively he ended the
fight and I think every father should
look to raise a son who doesn't start
fights but my goodness he should know
how to end them cleanly efficiently
that's it and so for me it was a very
gratifying moment to see that all the
effort all the years I put into teaching
my boy encouraging my boy to you know
with both boxing kickboxing and BJJ he
is mentally resilient he does stay calm
under pressure and even when he's being
attacked by somebody he can finish the
fight in a way that doesn't cause any
lasting damage he doesn't lose his call
and you know jump on anyone's head yeah
I think the fight sports are a very
Noble way to build a capable young man
but also a man of character a man of
ethics and mental resilience what else
uh what what are the fatherly advice do
you give to your son so okay you gotta
train to be able to defend himself
what other things that you teach him
instill in him and you advise other
parents to instill in their children to
bring him to be a a confident masculine
male definitely I mean this is a subject
to talk about for ages but the one thing
I've noticed in business is that the
value of persistence and Tate talks
about this you know you don't have to be
the smartest guy in the world but if
you're that guy who finds one way to to
add value to society and just doesn't
give up you know finds a skill that he
monetize and just works and works and
works that's where success lies and so
I've taught my son even at an early age
even when he was four or five
I say to my son what happens when things
get hard
so you keep going Papa and the way I
sort of drilled that into him is when we
do story time when I was putting the
kids to bed I'd tell them stories and
they could choose which way the story
went yeah I'd say to my son you're
walking up a hill to fight a dragon and
you know rescue a princess your legs are
getting tired what do you do do you give
up no papa I keep going now you're
fighting that Dragon you know your arms
are getting tired you know you're
sweating you're exhausted you give up no
papa keep going so now even to this day
if anyone says to my son what do you do
when when things get tough in life he'll
instantly say you keep going resilience
just look at that persistence is still
deep in his in his mind and I think
that'll really bring him benefits
throughout his life on a deep level a
big part of his identity is you know
you've got to put in the work even
nowadays I say to him say look
I said to my son look when your dad grew
up I didn't know what business was I
didn't know what money was my parents
you know both both broken on government
welfare handouts I said to my son with
the the benefits you've got with the
role models you've got around with the
exposure you have you know to business
to the big questions he asks about you
know Global Supply Chain about you know
macroeconomics and so on I said you have
the potential to to build build
businesses to build an Empire to do
incredibly well in life and his answer
is if I put the work in dad you know on
a deep level he is now holding himself
to account to know that he can be that
hero of his own story if he puts the
work in I think that's quite a noble
thing the other thing that I I really
program in if you will or you know role
model is I've made it very clear to my
son that there are agendas out there and
there are entities that want him to
adopt belief systems that are not in his
best interest to the point where he'll
sit and he'll watch Netflix and say oh
look Dad here we have a moment where a
girl a little a girl is going to beat up
10 guys you know he's calling out the
nonsense he even he pointed out to me oh
Dad I see on Netflix there's a girl
power section but there's no boy Power
set action now I'm not going to push my
Politics on my boy but I'll say why do
you think that is and then he knows that
there was a push against masculinity and
there's there's a push against you know
toxicity and there's this push to push
women up and his belief system is it's
good to push women up but you don't need
to push women down I don't need to push
men down sorry and he can see there is a
push against traditional masculinity and
I've made it clear for him that he can
choose his own belief systems in life he
doesn't have to listen to what the TV
says he doesn't have to listen to to you
know what adults are trying to push him
to believe he is the one who should
choose his own belief systems in life I
think that's a very important thing as a
parent you can't always be around to
explain something your kid might see on
on YouTube or to explain something your
kid might see on the street even you
have to teach them that there are
entities out there that want to program
you in a way and get you to adopt belief
systems that are not in your best
interest you have the right as a young
man to choose your own belief systems in
life be skeptical of people who are
trying to push their belief systems on
you that's something I'm quite
passionate about critical thinking
skills at a young age and understanding
that I mean without using those words
shaytan exists and he wants to make you
an unfulfilled unhappy easily controlled
sheep so you need to you need to watch
out for that and offset it and this is a
thing when people who have denied God
denied the Creator when they see all the
evil and I've had a a friend of mine who
used to be also somebody who's denying
but then he saw all the evil he said man
if there is a devil there has to be a
god obviously yeah and that's actually
Titan said that as well you cannot deny
that Satan exists look look at the way
shaytan has overtaken so many areas of
the west of Western culture we talk
about hip-hop culture we talk about you
know there's a different agendas being
pushed on children that just don't make
sense again you could never bring a
female stripper into a classroom but if
you bring a male stripper dressed up as
a woman that's fine all this blatant
nonsense you have to see that evil
exists so therefore by extension God has
to exist as well I think it's very it's
very clear in today's day and age
thank you brother really nice uh uh
talking with you uh any other words of
advice or anything else you want to I
mean yeah just to just to rehash I
really do believe that if you're a man
in today's world who has Traditional
Values yeah and you want to
be okay with those if you want to be
that provider that protector that man
who's stoic and mentally resilient
and you want to reject all of this
liberal programming this workers and
this this push towards Hedonism no go do
drugs you know go and explore your
sexuality go do whatever identify as a
coffee cup if you choose there is a way
with which to
protect those belief systems and to
understand them even better and that is
Islam and so I'd say to any man in the
west who is feeling that their belief
systems are weird and they are you know
perhaps being ostracized or negatively
judged for having traditional beliefs or
believing the traditional gender roles
are important within Islam and the ummah
there are people who have the same
beliefs as you and that you you can if
you if you adopt Islam and you practice
it earnestly you effectively have a
shield against all that wokeism that
liberalism that Hedonism which is a very
powerful thing it's an age-old thing and
so I think it's very positive to see
those men with traditional value values
such as myself such as the Tates
reverting to Islam and I think more and
more men who have those belief systems
especially in the west and they feel
those belief systems are under attack
Islam gives you a way to
realize that it's okay to have those
belief systems that having traditional
views is a positive thing understanding
the sacredness of the family unit is a
positive thing supporting traditional
gender roles is a positive thing Islam
gives you that that Guidance with which
to not only protect those belief systems
but to live true to them in a very
healthy very productive way uh and a
very clear code with which to live and I
really do hope that more and more men in
the west with Traditional Values close
to the heart consider Islam because I
think it's it's the only answer to to
the evil that you see in in liberalism
and workers and all these agendas being
pushed on kids and so on common sense
now is if you see someone like Andrew
Tate someone like you and many others
who are saying the same thing now it
behooves you to go ahead and pick up the
book this is the the one that um Dylan
he said Andrew Tate gifted him this I
think it was uh this one
and we actually so people go to the
dingshow.com we'll get this will be a
gift from me to you this is the book
this is the book that actually uh not
this particular one but Andrew Tate was
walking out of the Romanian jail with
the Quran correct and this is the one
that you you are telling people to to
Islam everything is here read the book
you know about Jesus read the book his
Blessed Mother read about the book about
tillheed pure monitories and purpose of
life where are you going when you die
everything is here in the book read the
book okay it's real the amount of depth
in that in that single text is
absolutely
life-alteringly mind-bendingly powerful
it's it's you cannot argue that the
power that that lies in that book is
like nothing else I've no I've not come
across anything like it my life
alhamdulillah thank you thank you very
again for being with us inshallah we
meet again
thank you so much that's a real honor
brother thank you Brothers we've been
told that uh they're out to kill us all
salam alaikum brothers and sisters we
went to the streets to ask Americans
about Islam here's what they said do you
know anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no sorry you know what Islam means Islam
uh no we've been told that uh they're
out to kill us all right that's what
you've been told that Muslims are out to
kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click the Donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign